mashko-pyro on it 153 special vokuev no
yes but for the Azov let them be on this
successfully help and from the territory to
today there are hours occupied by enemies and for pit
control in Ukraine and another 200
uncontrolled about this
time in busy with the enemy
to go further in pvr me to the
controlled territory of
ukraine it is necessary to exchange the
process of the field to the Turk and the apparatus itself
tearing off ct we assign clearly and with a
signifier and we can push this
information about its details the shards will be
information may be for  skoda, then the whole
process of
everything is nothing good from the normal
, the man will not know
whether anyone will insert from the very themselves, it already
starts in
butch irpin and less in places, well,
this is direct information, the account is
controlled by Russia, the territory of the beginning of the
knowledgeable export and but we really have a shop
pimples and just give thecus pro sown
usually
they are waiting for when and save them eat
once a day
which is natural they  they don’t tell us
because they don’t want to upset us,
but we ourselves understand what’s
going on there and
what kind of state, morally and
physically,
we hope for castration,
we want to achieve this
way out for them, I don’t, well, I don’t see
another,
but
you